[Musique]
c'était l'immeuble internationale il
faudra dorénavant l'appeler le car est
l'un des plus vieux bâtiments de
l'économie saint-quentinoise et cet
exploit qui vient de s'installer ici
bienvenue pour un nouveau numéro du 7-8
échos votre magazine consacré à
l'économie locale focus ce mois ci sur
l'immobilier d'entreprise avec cette
question comment les bureaux s'adapte
aux nouvelles activités des entreprises
tout de suite le sommet audi c'est le
nom du nouveau bâtiment du technocentre
renault de guyancourt actuellement en
construction entièrement en bois il
accueillera 700 collaborateurs du site
rencontre avec frédéric jammes senior
vice président en ile-de-france d'explo
avec lui nous parlerons de
l'installation du groupe dans le nouvel
immeuble le carré enfin le cluster
gennari ce groupe a lancé la
construction de son futur siège en
janvier 2019 des espaces de coworking
d'open innovation et d'intégration
technologique nous avons visité le
chantier
plusieurs chantiers sont actuellement en
cours à saint quentin en yvelines c'est
le cas du technocentre renault à
guyancourt son programme de rénovation
du site prévoit la construction
d'odyssée un nouveau bâtiment dont la
construction a commencé cet été
une visite était organisée mercredi 27
novembre regarder ce sera un bâtiment
tout en bois du sol au plafond une
nouvelle structure au sein du
technocentre renault de guyancourt son
nom odyssée une appellation choisie par
les collaborateurs du site
un chantier démarré cet été avec la pose
des premiers piliers en bois en octobre
dernier
vous voyez à cet endroit là l'assemblage
des poteaux des poutres et des planchers
qui se fait de façon simultanée donc de
façon très rapide
l'ensemble est et vi et là c'est la
partie qui va encore durer un mois et
demi à peu près pour élever la
principale structure
ensuite on va y apposer les façades ce
nouveau bâtiment de 12 mille mètres
carrés accueillera près de 700
collaborateurs
il s'inscrit dans le large projet de
rénovation du site
le programme efficience du technocentre
renault aujourd'hui tout a changé dans
les modes de travail en particulier dans
les modes de travail de l'ingénierie et
on a besoin
de se mettre en lien avec toutes les
nouveautés du mode de fonctionnement et
l'organisation dans l'espace doit être
en phase avec la manière dont les gens
travaillent
le nouvel immeuble va nous donner 700
places de plus qui va nous permettre de
vider entre guillemets la ruche pour
accélérer les travaux dans la ruche
effectivement les mobiliers innovants
que nous avions présenté il ya quelques
semaines seront dans ce bâtiment ce site
de recherche et développement ouvert ses
portes en 1998 il couvre une surface de
150 hectares et emploie près de onze
mille personnes
un site important pour l'économie du
territoire
la livraison du bâtiment est prévue pour
l'été prochain les collaborateurs
intégreront le site entre septembre et
novembre 2020
saint quentin en yvelines c'est un parc
d'immobilier d'entreprise de 4,6
millions de mètres carrés une surface
majoritaire de bureau il ya aussi des
sites de recherche et développement des
pme et des espaces dédiés à la
logistique à l'industrie l'immobilier
d'entreprise en chiffres sur un montage
de romans russes fini
[Musique]
oh
nous avons rejoint frédéric j'aime
bonjour bonjour vous êtes senior vice
président en ile-de-france du groupe
expliquent aux expériences et plus de 15
mille collaborateurs répartis dans 25
pays
un chiffre d'affaires de plus d'un
milliard d'euros en 2018 alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer en quoi
consiste l'activité et notamment sur le
site de saint quentin en yvelines
oui bien sûr donc exploit est un groupe
d'ingénierie qui est spécialisé dans le
monde de l'automobile de l'aéronautique
du ferroviaire initialement et qui s'est
doté l'année dernière d'une forte
implantation dans le monde de la banque
et de la finance avec l'acquisition du
groupe est ce qu est ce donc aujourd'hui
effectivement nous avons comme je le
disais 15000 personnes qui travaillent
dans 25 pays et sur le site de saint
quentin
nous avons un gros gros pôles de
compétences dans le secteur de
l'automobile c'est là où nous avons
énormément de développer notre savoir
faire nos activités avec des clients qui
sont en proximité qui sont des grands
comptes de la région que ce soit en haut
ou psa ou des industriels de rang 1 que
nous accompagnons dans leurs projets à
la fois de véhicule dans les innovations
qui peuvent mettre dans ces nouveaux
véhicules vous avez certainement entendu
parler des véhicules autonomes voir vous
les avez conduit et bien il ya beaucoup
d'innovations derrière cela nous les
accompagnons sur ces sujets là et nous
avons également avec les années pris le
parti de d'étendre cette cette
compétence pour adresser le monde du
ferroviaire
le monde de l'aéro du spatial de la
défense puisque c'est un énorme secteur
aussi du périmètre ile-de-france donc
voilà
globalement ce que nous avons développé
et qui nous sommes dans la région ile de
france vous venez de vous installer ici
dans l'immeuble le caresser le bâtiment
historique de l'économie 56 noise
pourquoi avoir fait ce choix en fait
d'avoir de nouveaux locaux alors là
c'était une longue réflexion menée par
la direction nous avons un changement
générationnel depuis quelques années en
fait tous les deux ans on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya une nouvelle génération qui
arrive
et qui arrive avec de nouveaux styles
nouvelle approche une nouvelle manière
de travailler
ces générations l'appareil la génération
y et puis la génération z et puis on
sait plus comment les nommer parce que
ça ça évolue très vite et on a la
nécessité d'offrir à ces assez nos
équipes finalement un cadre de travail
qui correspond à leur manière de
fonctionner à leur usage est donc il va
leur permettre d'avoir des zones
différentes en fonction de leur état en
fonction de ce qu'ils ont envie de faire
en fonction de leur activité
on a pris le parti c'est un projet qui a
duré plus de deux ans et demi nous avons
été accompagnés par des professionnels
et nous avons pris le parti de casser
les codes des open space où bien des
bureaux ou ki-nam n'est pas satisfaction
par rapport à ces changements
générationnels et de créer des espaces
avec des zones des zones dédiées ici
nous sommes dans une zone que nous
appelons silence zone de concentration
qui se veut très très calme
à côté de cela nous avons des zones de
collision on appelle ces zones là donc
c'est quand les les équipes veulent se
croiser différentes fonctions travailler
sur des sujets elles peuvent nous allons
désormais il ya aussi des salles où les
équipes peuvent faire des brainstorm
peuvent travailler ensemble sur des
sujets et puis des territoires
d'équipement où ils peuvent toujours se
retrouver ils savent qu'ils ont leur
place ici ou une place qui leur est qui
leur est attribué et qu'ils peuvent qui
peuvent l'utiliser avec avec leur équipe
voilà on voit et puis il ya du matériel
innovant on voit avec park a dû battre
ce type de fauteuil
comment justement l'immobilier le
matériel s'adapte à l'innovation des
entreprises alors l'innovation à la fois
technique dans leurs activités mais
aussi à l'innovation dans le management
donc on a voulu effectivement avoir des
espaces qui permettent aux équipes de se
retrouver dans un mix à la fois 2
de chaleur de se retrouver presque comme
chez eux vous voyez on a des fauteuils
qui se prêtent aussi gars assez
facilement ou à la lecture au calme en
tout cas des systèmes de bull qui
permettent de rester en tension très
attentif sur l'interlocuteur pour éviter
également
donc on a voulu avoir des espaces avec
un mobilier qui s'adapte finalement aux
besoins de chacun et effectivement tout
temps la journée nous allons entrer dans
cette salle et voir des populations de
différentes à différents moments qui
vont utiliser différents types de
mobiliers après le repas c'est rare
qu'ils s'installent sur ces types de
deux mobiliers par contre voilà donc on
a joué là dessus on a l'exemple avec
cette salle alors plutôt de
concentration une zone de silence
quels sont les autres lieux où le
matériel l'espace a été modifié alors il
ya un espace qui est assez central est
que nous sommes en train de développer
que ça fait deux mois que nous sommes
arrivés cellino valable lino globe se
veut être un espace ou à certaines
heures de la journée les équipes peuvent
se retrouver en général entre midi et
deux en fin de journée pour travailler
sur leurs sujets de recherche et pour
justement ma tâche est d'amener ramener
de l'innovation il ya beaucoup de
technologies il ya beaucoup de l'espace
de bricolage où ils peuvent travailler
leur concept leurs prototypes des
espaces de présentation aussi qui leur
permet d'avancer
puis nous avons des espaces dédiés à des
zones de clients ou là ce sont vraiment
des espaces traditionnels où les équipes
peuvent travailler en général il ya
beaucoup d'intensité dans c'est dans ces
lieux là et puis ensuite vous allez
trouver des espaces confidentiel défense
puisque nous avons un étage qui a été
dédiée à des projets qui sont réservées
aux clients issus de la défense vous
savez que dans la région nous avons
beaucoup
donc il nous permet d'héberger des
projets à haute sensibilité dans des
conditions de sécurité idéal donc là
c'est un autre espace est également un
qui s'y prêtent et puis au dernier étage
8e c'est toute la partie coquine qui
grouillent en général de monde avec
l'espace également de détente
il ya quelques baby foot il ya de quoi
se restaurer avec une terrasse qui
permet aux collaborateurs vraiment de
pouvoir faire des pauses ou alors
travailler en équipe de manière plus
brillante que ce qu'on peut avoir ici
pour échanger les idées
maîtres de l'énergie déjà merci beaucoup
je vous en prie senior vice président en
ile-de-france du groupe explose et
maintenant direction magny les hameaux
avec un autre projet immobilier
d'envergure sur le territoire
ces boeufs ben alouane le futur siège de
generix group c'est actuellement en
construction ce nouveau site va
permettre d'accélérer le développement
du cluster composé de plusieurs start up
nous sommes allés visiter le chantier
regarder un étage et demi d'activité d
un étage de fab lab un otage de bureau
aujourd'hui ils sont installés à magny
les hameaux demain les 250
collaborateurs de generix group
occuperont ce bâtiment à guyancourt
bubble one le futur siège multi usages
de ce cluster lancé en janvier 2019 le
chantier devrait se conclure en février
2020 on a souhaité donc être
propriétaire de l'immeuble pour être
donc à notre à la disposition de nos
activités et du projet de cluster de
pouvoir héberger des porteurs de projets
des des start up et puis bien évidemment
prendre en compte aussi l'évolution du
groupe qui est en croissance permanente
une croissance de près de 30% ce cluster
est composé de plusieurs start up
pluridisciplinaire engagés dans
l'innovation différentes infrastructures
sont prévues ce hall occupera une
plateforme d'intégration de systèmes sur
plusieurs types de véhicules des outils
conçus au premier étage on arrive dans
la zone bureau d'études pour concevoir
les produits qui sont fabriqués à
l'étagé en dessous au centre donc il est
prévu que l'on est à des zones de
travail collaboratives nous avons donc
essayé de
de placer un certain nombre de salles de
réunion et on va jusque à la faune boxe
il permet de faire une colle conférence
soin de soi tout seul ou bien même
prendre une communication privée le
caser cherves des espaces flexibles
multi-usages de coworking de co-création
d'open innovation nous arrivons à la
partie belle femme donc la partie open
génération c'est une structure capable
de recevoir à la fois des clients qui
nous expriment des besoins recevoir des
porteurs de projets recevoir des start
up qui nous présentent leur technologie
enfin le toit du bâtiment va servir de
terrasse il est prévu aussi des
installations pour la consommation
énergétique du bâtiment s'est installé
un système solaire sur la toiture s'est
récupéré certes énergie solaire dans un
stockeur et se stocker restituera cette
énergie sur des bornes de voitures
électriques et dans l'infrastructure du
bâtiment près de six millions d'euros
ont été investis dans ce projet humble
tout est humble souris pourrait voir le
jour dans les prochaines années
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis vous pouvez revoir ce
numéro en replay sur notre site internet
ou sur l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]